how is Atlanta I even I just heard
somebody talking that even like going to
Buckhead is hot right now yeah man look
at when we're coming home City right now
I heard like you could you like they're
doing the smash and grabs and Buckhead
again like because you know Buckhead you
could usually go to Atlanta you're like
I'm going to Buckhead it's the night
it's The Burbs yeah Buckhead right I
heard it's hot over there right now
let's say Atlanta man you know yeah the
young boy it's hot everywhere though
with Buckhead is LA's [ __ ] up too
you've been but uh yeah uh but Buckhead
is definitely hotter than usual you know
what I'm saying I know a lot like I just
said they're trying to get their own um
their own County uh on police they they
don't want to be part of Atlanta no more
they want their own City okay I want to
be their own city are you feeling the
temperature in Atlanta change now that
we kind of know that this D.A that's
there is specifically targeting rappers
uh in terms of just like are you
noticing it just from like somebody
who's a part of the industry and also
somebody who's a fan of what's going on
in Atlanta are you noticing the music
change maybe the subject matter changing
people moving out or people moving
differently
um I would definitely say it's been a
big change since that D.A ass got in uh
office you know what I'm saying but like
I say always man I feel like us as
rappers man we really gotta watch what
we put out because like I'm and I mean
as in lyrics like you just said like if
I'm talking about gang I mean like Shoot
Em Up Bang Bang music in my songs what
you think gonna be well what type of
crowd do I think gonna be in my show or
what type of crowd do I think that I'm
gonna you know get the attention of so
it's almost like and you get attention
from everywhere not just like it's gonna
come from everywhere so you just gotta
be mindful of what we say man and like I
you know
same plan she ain't playing she ain't
playing
I feel like you've been somebody who's
for the most part
had just Positive Vibes oh yeah like you
know like you know like I'm from the
hood uh but I don't got a rap about life
what's going on and I could just rap
about the Hood from my perspective of it
and just give stories and just put your
own game well I ain't trying to go bad
though I don't mean like
but I could still make you feel pain
music without having to rap about that
you feel me I'm just trying to rap about
some everyday situations man stuff that
you can relate to everybody can relate
to shoot no gun yeah I